[Music]
hey what's up
mkbhd here welcome to 2021 so
this is the oneplus one
and this is the oneplus 8
pro and the oneplus story
is a really fascinating one so when
people ask me like in real life
hey what phone do you use and i say it's
a oneplus 8 pro
the phone i use is called the oneplus 8
pro
the reaction is always one of two things
they either draw a total blank
and they have never heard of oneplus and
they have to be filled in on what
oneplus
is or they already know about it and
they pull one out of their pocket too
and now maybe they already saw the
reviews
and they love the thing it's actually
gotten to the point where it's become a
defining characteristic
of the oneplus brand it's a really
popular
enthusiast smartphone brand where people
really know about it
in the community already but in the
outside world they're still trying to
break into
this mainstream where everyone's heard
of them but there's a really great quote
from the dark knight you might heard
about it where you either die a hero
or live long enough to see yourself
become the villain
and loki that's kind of slowly what's
been happening to oneplus
over the past couple years let me
explain
so from the beginning and this is an
important fact to sort of keep in the
back of your head for all this
oneplus is a brand owned and managed by
a company called
bbk electronics and that company
also runs the brands for oppo
vivo and realme so while all these
companies are
sort of viewed as independent and
they're independently managed and run
they're also kind of related like
brothers
so anyway okay the oneplus story starts
pretty hot right
they're the new kid on the block they're
a fresh face and their
first phone is a pretty massive success
it's a
the oneplus one and this phone
especially in the enthusiast community
catches on instantly you know they can
barely keep up with orders
they have this wild invite only purchase
system to get your hands on it
and the phone is hard to get right off
the bat and the reason that this phone
is such a massive success is because
it's positioned
perfectly as maybe the original
flagship killer so it's coming from a
new upstart company
that's not spending millions on
marketing they're really listening to
comments
and their forums and they're delivering
features enthusiasts really want
and they have an incredible price to
performance ratio they partnered with
cyanogenmod for the software for a
custom
near stock android experience it was
like a souped-up version of the nexus 5.
they didn't cut corners with specs and
performance and they added features with
software updates and they were active
within their community and it all comes
from this young hungry upstart that kind
of feels like
a startup that was the kind of energy i
could get behind
i really liked this phone when it came
out
and i feel like if you're putting
together a list of like the best phones
of the last decade
i think this has to be on it so oneplus
as a company starts building up from
that
right and there's a few botched
marketing campaigns here and there i
suspect just from them not really being
very familiar with this new market
they're working with
but very quickly they've broken in and
they just carve out this identity as
being
the new enthusiast phone with bang for
the buck
but remember remember that fact i told
you to keep in mind from the beginning
of the video
oneplus is a new company but they're not
exactly
a new company remember they're a sub
brand alongside vivo and oppo and realme
so while a lot of their phones and their
startup style management
is really fun if you've paid attention
over the past couple years
to some of their designs and even their
oldest stuff
a lot of oneplus phones are also
oppo phones it goes all the way back to
that oneplus one
came out around the same time as the
oppo find seven
two different phones from two different
companies but related companies
so the hardware shares a lot of parts
and most of the substantial difference
is in the software since oppo is
targeting one market and oneplus is
targeting another
same idea with the oneplus 5 and the
oppo are 11. i mean put them side by
side and tell me without the logo you
could tell these apart
a little bit after that there was
oneplus 6t that looked a lot like
oppo r17 and even today you have oneplus
new nord n100 which is visually almost
indistinguishable
from oppo's a53 and even some oppo
technologies like luke charging
get rebranded and included in oneplus
phones as dash charging
now none of this is a
bad thing so how do i bring this up
well the oneplus brand
has been evolving right in front of our
eyes clearly they started off this
company that was very focused with one
phone per year
bringing the hype with the maximum value
for the lowest price
and diving deep into enthusiast features
and listening to users and forums and on
social media
all of that but that isn't sustainable
by itself
the enthusiast market is a tiny fraction
of the entire market
and so while being the enthusiast
favorite is great
they definitely want to leverage that
status to be able to sell to the whole
rest of the market and so we've seen
lots of attempts at that over the years
first of all
their flagship pricing as you've seen
has slowly crept up
year over year so the oneplus one
started
at 299 when it first came out flagship
killer status
and it's slowly bumped up over the years
to now oneplus 8 pro
starts at 8.99 so they have those early
phones starting with one plus one
one plus two one plus three but they
also tried phones like the oneplus x
which were more fashion focused they
started dropping more phones per year
with a t
version and a pro versus non-pro version
and their latest attempt
the nord which has turned into a
full-blown line of budget
phones in different regions for
different low prices now to the
enthusiast
this may seem disappointing like they
aren't as focused
as they once were with this one
hard-hitting phone per
year to slay the giants as they now go
chasing the mainstream and so there's
this pretty new narrative playing out in
headlines and comments that oneplus is
sort of turning into oppo with all these
new phones that are coming out
but if you've been paying attention then
you already know
oneplus has been taking pages from
oppo's playbook
since the very beginning and both
companies along with pretty much every
other
major smartphone company wants to sell
eventually
to as many people as possible so there's
a really great video by fellow youtuber
tech alter
i've recommended it before it's an oldie
but a gay but you should watch it
on the theory of enthusiast brands
and basically his theory is there's
almost no way
that an enthusiast brand doesn't
eventually disappoint you
because there's only two ways their
future can go either they will move on
from enthusiasts
and try to eventually sell to the rest
of the world the mainstream buyer
which is a little disappointing or they
continue to try to appeal to
the most fickle crowd in the world
that is also the smallest and eventually
find that that's not good enough to
sustain a business
and they die and that's also pretty
disappointing so the moral of the story
today
is don't be a fanboy meaning don't
become
such a fan of a company that they can
eventually
betray you and let you down be a fan of
the products
themselves so if a company you like
drops a bad product
maybe it's time to consider other
options it sounds super simple because
it is
but a lot of people don't have quite the
same luxury people working at oneplus
for example
probably feel differently about the
company they work for today
than when they started especially if
they've been working for the company for
a long time
matter of fact many people from that
company's early days have left so the
oneplus story
has been pretty crazy you know on one
hand it is pretty
unusual to see i mean it's pretty rare
and actually kind of refreshing
that you see a new brand or a fresh face
sort of break in
and disrupt things and shake it up a
little bit but on the other hand
you either die a hero or live long
enough to see yourself
become the villain now this isn't to say
oneplus is like done and they'll never
make another good phone again and
they're going to become evil
no i actually think they've sort of
created a dna that will allow them to
probably keep making a lot of really
good phones phones that i continue to
use and like
i'm sure that'll keep happening but i
think if you're looking for the best
bang for the buck or even the the most
enthusiast focused
smartphone brand well that's new shoes
to be filled
that's going to be a sort of a rotating
spot at the moment seems to be a lot of
red me a lot of poco
and probably some new brands coming up
will be in there too so either way
that's been it
thanks for watching and uh let me know
if you guys enjoy these sort of
explainer videos like this i had a lot
of fun with them so
hopefully you do too anyway catch you
guys
in the next one peace